ناصر اليوم الى المجموعه الثانيه في كاس
العالم والتي تضم منتخبات انجلترا وايران
والولايات المتحده يعد المنتخب الانجليزي
واحدا بين ثمانيه منتخبات توجد بكاس
العالم وكان ذلك في نسبه عام 66 عندما فاز
بلقب الوحيد على ارض المتفوقا على المانيا
الغربيه باربعه اهداف مقابل هدفين واستلم
كاس جورني من الملكه الرحله
[تصفيق]
في مشاركتها التاليه
وانتظرت سنوات طويله حتى بلغت نصف نعيم
مونديال 90 الا ان المانيا فازت عليها
بركلات الترجي وعندما واجهت ايطاليا
المستضيفه في مباراه تحديدا مرتبه الثالثه
خسرت بهدفين بهدف واحد لن تتاهل انجلترا
الى نسبه كاس العالم بالولايات المتحده
عام 94 لكنها عادت بقوه في النساء
للمنتخب الانجليزي في مدير روسيا كان
يتمثل في حصول القائد هاري كين على لقب
هداف في هذه البطوله الدراسيه سته من
المفارقه ان منتخب انجلترا هو الوحيد بين
المتواجدين بكاس العالم الذي لم يحصل على
لقب في قارته كان قريبه من ذلك في بطوله
اوروبا في يوليو من العام الماضي لكنه خسر
امام ايطاليا لم تواجه انجلترا بقياده
المدرب ساوثبيت اي صعوبه في تصفيات كاس
العالم في قطر وتصدرت مجموعتها دون خساره
محققه ثمانيه انتصارات وتعدلينه وسجلت 39
هدفا في 10 مباريات بينها اثنى عشر هدفا
لنجمتين بين استقبلت ثلاثه اهداف فقط في
مباراه الاولى في كاس العالم في قطر
ستواجه وانجلترا المنتخب الايراني تستادي
خليف الدولي عند ساعه الرابعه عصرا بتوقيت
مكه المكرمه
[موسيقى]